[Music]
I'm the one
[Music]
pdb or pbd pdb pdb why pdb president's
Daily Brief when I started at the CIA
yeah the gold standard is do you get in
front of the president every day the
president gets what we call the book
it's actually depending on the president
it can be a pamphlet it can be a binder
but it's referred to as a pdb the
president's Daily Brief it's the it's
the short summary of stuff going around
the world that you think you'd be
interested in through articles maybe
some shorts you know a couple sentences
now let me ask you this you think the
current president enjoys the pdb or he
skips them no because he was on the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee so
it's somebody's name he has to go
through it guys welcome to the pdb
podcast
let me tell you we're back at it again
we're trying to solve a mystery so for
me I'm like look we got to bring xci
agency or xfbi agents so finally we said
look why don't we bring somebody that's
been both CIA and FBI and that's our
guest today uh let me properly read the
intro so you know who we're talking to
today uh he is an American political
commentator former counterterrorism
official in the CIA and the FBI he
joined the CIA
n85 as an analyst specializing in South
Asia Middle East and 92 he joined the
cia's counterterrorism center CTC from
95 to 98 he served on a National
Intelligence Council as a deputy
National Intelligence officer for the
near east and south Asia and all one he
began policies uh assignment at the
White House detailed from the CIA to
serve as the Director of golf Affairs on
the White House National Security
Council and then he's done a bunch of
different things after that I think he
was back at the CI from 2002 I think
around 2010 a little bit of stuff from
2009 10 with the FBI and then eventually
the debate is whether he left whether he
got fired or he quit but I want to find
out what happened why did you leave the
CIA at the end that's the mystery that's
the question okay in 2010 let's be let's
be clear I did not retire I quit you're
the first person and you're starting off
on the wrong foot to suggest that I got
fired I did not get you know what this
reminds me of have you seen have you
seen uh Larry King with uh what's the
guys and the comedian you like did you
comedian uh Jerry Seinfeld he sits there
he says so so Jerry why did they fire
you wait you think I got fired Larry you
think I got fired are you is this
serious have you seen this or no yes
well of course Classic on that so what's
up no we're gonna start brawling here
you know 25 years of service you think
somebody would say thanks and he says
did you get fired but there's there's a
real story I was
one of the problems in the Thousand
problems in the American government is
the is the president's responsible for
nominating too many people for too many
jobs so I got nominated by President
Obama whom I did not know one of my
friends put me up for the job to
President Obama to be the head of
intelligence at Homeland Security
I had been deputy director of the cia's
counterterrorism center at the time
where we had so-called black sites where
we kept Al Qaeda prisoners and we
conducted what are called Renditions
that is transferring Al Qaeda prisoner
to RCI facility so I was involved in
some of that by the time President Obama
nominated me for a position at
Department of Homeland Security in 2009
the Congress was all over Renditions and
black sites and they said when you come
down for your open that is public
nomination hearing
the Democrats are going to kick your ass
one way and the Republicans are going to
kick your ass another way and I said
well neither of you is because if that's
your goal I'm out that's not
professional and I'm not going to
participate so the real to be really
serious for a moment challenge for me
was
um after 25 years of a paycheck every
other Friday stepping out and saying I
don't have a job
and I don't know what my job's going to
be and I'm going to I'm going to lose my
pension and I still don't have it for a
seven year period from 55 to 62. I'm 16
60 now so it's still another couple
years till I get a pension so I know
this is boring but as a government
bureaucrat and I use that word that's
painful to say but I was to step away
from a paycheck and say I quit because
I'm pissed off at the Senate that was
tough but that's what happened I just
said I'm not going up for a hearing
where you just abuse me in public about
the interrogation program that's that's
what it was when you said I'm done with
this that's correct yes I said I'm out
all my friends said you're nuts another
seven years and you can get a pension I
said life is not about waking up in the
morning for seven years of life and
saying you know maybe six months I would
have done it and saying I'm going to do
something because I could never get a
great job after you turned down a
presidential appointment that never
happens unless you don't pay taxes on
your Nanny you never willfully pull away
especially as a bureaucrat you never
pull away from a presidential
appointment when you start as a gs9
making twenty three thousand dollars a
year and the President appoints you to a
position
so my point is after you pull away from
one my career would have been over and
I'm not going to sit around for seven
years just waiting for a pension that's
not like was that was that a shot at a
man named Bernie when you said the taxes
on Nanny did we Carrick remember the
whole thing oh no no no back no they're
everything I thought I swear you and I'm
like that was uh no no no no there's a
lot of back you're going I'm going to
date myself 20 years or so there's a
whole series of um they're a whole
series of
uh public officials including justices
Etc who who did not succeed in getting
their jobs because they had a nanny from
Latin America and they didn't pay taxes
which I thought was
a bit much but uh yeah people usually
pull out from appointments what I was
trying to save for cause and the cause
is usually some ethical issue not just
because they're pissed off at the Senate
no good for you for doing that so for
some of us
uh on the who are not CIA agents or FBI
agents who live normal lives can you
kind of you know I know a lot of things
are said here with the projects you
worked on assignments you worked on what
what were some regions
maybe even countries that you worked on
you know since 1985 boy a lot of my
India Pakistan Sri Lanka uh Iran
worked a lot on Middle East stuff
including places like Saudi Arabia when
I was deputy director of counter
terrorism from 0.205 so that's you know
obviously after 9 11 dealing with uh
dealing with Afghanistan I was in
Afghanistan
with the team to put together a new
government in November and December of
2001 which was an incredible experience
with a guy named Ambassador Dobbins who
was the the man who basically put
together the new government after we we
moved into the army and intelligence Etc
moved into Afghanistan so Middle East
South Asia generally and doing a lot of
counterterrorism stuff for a lot of
years from your perspective what is the
difference between the the job duties of
a CIA agent and FBI obviously we've
heard it many times by folks I think in
the last eight weeks we've had two or
three CI agents and FBI agents sitting
right here right on the podcast with us
but what would you say is the difference
between a CI agent and an FBI agent well
let me do better than they did because
clearly they didn't educate you so let
me see if I can
shots fired you thought this was good
all the time yeah it's gonna be okay I
like it already there's a there's a a
couple one that's sort of clear and one
that's less clear let's do fact and
culture fact would be the FBI typically
is domestically focused they have a lot
of people overseas but that is a
secondary purpose for the FBI so so
investigating things like white-collar
crime uh Enron years ago investigating
organized crime investigating obviously
counterterrorism child pornography gangs
uh right now White supremacists
uh in the CI which is obviously
typically focused on overseas the
Iranian nuclear program the North Korean
missile program what's going on in
Ukraine right now there but I think the
the one of the most interesting things I
saw spent
25 years at the CIA the last five I was
on detail to director Mueller the
Mueller who did the Russia report I was
his intelligence advisor at the FBI from
05 to 2010.
culturally the FBI is much more formal
Much More hierarchical Much More rules
oriented because you have to bring your
information into a court of law and
that's public and you can be questioned
by a defense attorney so the culture at
the CIA is fundamentally different
flatter to be blunt less respectful of
leadership which has ups and downs yes
you you can walk into the CI director in
my case my most frequent interaction was
daily with with CI director tenant and
the conversations are can be pretty Toe
to Toe you do not do that with yet with
yes when you say toe to toes
yes it's not impolite it's a director we
can't do that that's not a good idea we
should do this I did not see people
interact with Robert and Robert
Mueller's personality was also he's a
he's a different personality um maybe
the best leader I ever saw in Washington
DC and that's that's saying a lot
so both have advantages but I was saying
the CI is more informal uh less rules
oriented because you're operating
overseas and you're not collecting
information on what we call non-uspers
non-us persons so the rights a non-us
person has to privacy when they're
looking at her their email is a lot
different than the rights you might have
despite what people say in sort of
conspiracy media the rights you might
have logging in in Fort Lauderdale or
Chicago or Los Angeles very different
very different worlds and Philip how
long were ucia versus FBI 25 years at
CIA but the last five the CI director
said you're going to go over the FBI and
help them build an intelligence program
uh back then there are a lot of
questions about how the FBI how
aggressively the FBI was trying to
follow potential people in the United
States who are joining Al-Qaeda later to
become Isis so I was paid by the CI when
I was at the FBI but I sat in the
Executive Suite of the FBI down the hall
from director Mueller so in essence
you're sort of you're immersed which was
a weird seeing both cultures was really
instructive one of the best experiences
of my life personally and professionally
I'd say you said um culturally wise uh
you you gave a clear distinction between
how people operate internally with the
FBI versus the CIA but you were fcia for
25 years a little a little more less
structure everything you sort of
encompassed with that uh but then when
you went to FBI you kind of had to more
tow the line you had to be I don't want
to say less respectful I'm sorry more
respectful but you basically had to kind
of fall in line versus CIA you could be
a more loosey-goosey with it how did you
process that I think one of the you know
there's a lot of leadership questions I
do some Executive coaching now and some
public speaking it's surprising how many
of the lessons of leadership and
management
you see outside government I didn't
expect this outside government that I
witnessed inside government the only
reason I can say that is because in my
first 20 years at the CIA I knew one
thing this is how we operate especially
operating in a world that's not visible
to the public where you think you're
everything the lack of humility I'll get
in trouble with my friends for this at
the cia's
significant because they think that
they're everything and again in a secret
world you don't have competition you're
not questioned
um going over the FBI I started to
realize hey these folks are much more
rigorous in how they ask questions now
again that has some downsides that
sometimes eliminates risk-taking but we
can learn from that the FBI is much more
metrics oriented we can learn from that
how we measure performance instead of
saying you know Joe's pretty good let's
assume that what he's doing you know
that what he's doing is succeeding well
it's not so you're going to hold Joe's
feet to the fire by adding a little
metrics to the equation
I I just saw the differences as profound
and I don't mean to be critical of
either organization but I think both
have something to learn from the other
and
sometimes they're incapable of it
because there's still rivalry between
the two uh so it's a little bit what's
wondering why do you think the American
people trust these organizations
the lack of trust they have for these
organizations today why do you think
it's gotten to that point I think it's
pretty simple and this is a leadership
question and I I anticipated in the age
of social media and the internet that
people would become better educated that
more access to more information meant
that people would be broader that people
would be open to looking at more stuff
and what you realize obviously whichever
end of the spectrum you're on is that
people go down and they want validation
I think this I'm going to have an Avenue
for information that reflects this I
mean I'm not giving you a revelation
here in terms of your questions about
lack of trust in institutions people who
are going down those rat holes left and
right
still value leadership and I this is a
positive thing but it's also a negative
thing if leadership propaganda is about
a consistent message over time that has
some little kernel of truth if
leadership consistently says don't trust
these people watch out for Mar-A-Lago
watch out for January 6 watch out for
the rest and Russia investigation left
to right they're not don't trust them
because they're not doing what an
American should expect the Ci or the FBI
does people are eventually and people
are susceptible to propaganda in this
country we think we're not we are people
eventually are going to say I believe
that if it's told consistently over the
course of years down a rat hole and
someone's told the same messages so
they're so I blame leadership I don't
blame the institutions they're not
responsible for public diplomacy and
convincing Americans why they're doing
the right thing the FBI is not a public
affairs organization and I object to
members of Congress saying the FBI
should be more out there explaining
itself they're an investigative
organization they're not there to
influence American perspectives I blame
leadership for telling people not to
trust these institutions and over time
they won and people don't trust them so
let's go through a series of uh issues
that have happened uh in the last few
years that caused the public to kind of
uh uh react to it okay and and give your
uh feedback on each level of credibility
and I'll kind of go through them one by
one by one I'd be Kirsten hope to hear
from you by the way if I miss something
Tyler jump in there and Adam add your
stuff that I forgot as well no don't
make this more complicated no you just
go prototype so for me so let's go
through Benghazi uh let's write that
down Benghazi uh let's write down the
thirty thousand emails let's write down
Russia collusion with Trump
let's write down a January 6
insurrection
let's write down the two impeachments
let's write down the Mar-A-Lago raid
what did I miss you have I missed any
Kardashians I mean how much do you want
to know Gretchen winner kidnapping is
that something yeah uh that's
interesting we can put it up I'm I'm
talking about some of the any of this
stuff that's the big stuff that's
happened birtherism Obama I don't know
okay
that's more marketing that's more
marketing but you know it's not um
dementia everything I don't think
Ukraine specifically putting it um
let's put that 100 Biden uh the story
New York Post they knew it they held it
back even Zuckerberg talked about it on
Rogan's podcast so so these events
happen the average person that doesn't
have access to information like you do
like others do
they sit there and people want to
believe it they want to believe yeah
that's what's happening you know and
then you know some sites rather than
well let's let's prove it we've become
this society that everybody is guilty
until proven innocent and instead of uh
innocent until proven guilty when you
hear somebody's story you know where are
you at with well that one I don't know
what they did with that there was no
point with this one that one had
credibility this one ended up being a
hoax that one was a waste of time how do
you process these
boy that's a great question um let's we
can we'll spend the next it's a 9 23 a.m
East Coast um let me just give you a
couple thoughts and we can go into
whatever Direction you want the first is
I might have missed one or two I let me
take birtherism off the table I look at
all of these and say they're worthy of
an investigation they're worthy of
looking at to determine what happened
Connor Biden 30 000 emails what happened
in terms of uh Donald Trump Jr's meeting
with a with a Russian
to get dirt on Hillary before the
campaign I mean before the election all
these things are worthy of looking at
there's a couple of characteristics
um that I look at as someone who did
this for a living to see which ones get
over the bar
let me give you two or three
um one is you mentioned Benghazi that's
loss of life that's not only worth
looking at
that's worth stepping back and saying is
we have to have an after action to
determine whether there's some way to
prevent this in the future
loss of life to me takes a problem to a
different
to a different cat versus the Hillary
Clinton 30 000 emails I mean there
wasn't loss of life so you got to
investigate that to turn to determine
whether there's a civil or criminal
penalty but that's at a lesser level
the second thing and this is where it
gets really subtle but to my mind really
important is the difference between what
you think and what you know particularly
when the question of what you know is
going to go into court of law where
there's a defense attorney and a
prosecutor
so you can say let's go to Mar-A-Lago
and I'll I'll give you both sides you
can say as someone who looked at
classified information I can see that
the cover sheets on the photo that came
out of Mar-A-Lago
and I can say that stuff is extremely
sensitive in my world some of that stuff
I would not have had access to and the
reason it's sensitive is that if it were
released to uh to the public
the people we're collecting against Iran
North Korea Russia example would be able
to figure out where that came from in a
heartbeat and shut down that Avenue
including potentially it's if it's a
human informant that's a traitor they're
going to kill him
so that's one aspect to it so somebody
would say well if he's got that stuff in
Mar-A-Lago well of course he's guilty
why haven't they charged him yet then I
look at it and say well if you want to
talk about the former president United
States it's not clear me exactly what he
told the people when that information
was removed from the White House it's
not clear to me what happened when it
got to Mar-A-Lago in terms of clear
direction from the president I'm not
telling you about what you think and
what we've heard reported I'm talking
about what you can say in a court of law
the former president doesn't write
emails so you're not going to produce an
email and he's got a bunch of advisors
who probably heard different things so
you're going to have conflicting
evidence going to a trial so when I look
at stuff to really get over the bar on
this stuff I'm going through a process
an analytic process of let me make
arguments both sides and I when I train
analysis I tell people if you believe
one thing you are only a good analyst
when you can go to the other side and
make an argument to me that's compelling
about what you're what the person on the
other side of the table thinks you have
to have your mind in at a level of
flexibility where you're seeing both
sides I would say on most of these click
to close
Benghazi is an example the 30 000 emails
are example mar-a-lago's sort of an
example the stories are subtler than
people think and finally there's far
less conspiracy than people think we
don't do conspiracies well in government
and I'm not joking you know if you have
a hundred people going uh looking at the
Mar-A-Lago problem
one person trying to affect that because
they don't like President Trump or they
do is very very very difficult to do and
let me rephrase that that's impossible I
just don't see it so take the conspiracy
crap out but put your hat on of saying
before I go down a rabbit hole of my
perspective make the other argument and
it's more difficult than it sounds you
know how hard it is to believe what you
just said that the the
uh the conspiracies of people not liking
somebody is out the window or liking
somebody is out the window because uh
that I think that's the biggest problem
I have and let me explain what I mean by
this
uh for me CIA maybe CIA more than FBI
but maybe we can put FBI in that as well
uh oh I have a hard time you know
believing that they can stay neutral
I have a very hard time believing that
they can stay neutral and then the
problem I go to is how the hell do you
recruit people that don't have their own
political leanings where they're not
going to be jumping to conclusion with
their own you know ideology or you know
relationships that they have it almost
hurts it right like when Stephen A Smith
talks I don't know if you follow Stephen
A Smith okay yeah can we give our
opinion here yeah so check this out so
with Stephen I said by the way he
irritates a lot of people right but
anytime Stephen A Smith wants to give
feedback about Magic Johnson I don't
hear it because it's his best friend
so when you become too close to these
players you can't uh give real feedback
because you're gonna have dinner with
this guy and you want to keep a
relationship with them but we're in CI
and FBI a lot of these guys can't stand
a lot of these types of personalities
like I can imagine and to see how like
what Peter struck did it was very
obvious when his text came out
uh this guy hated Trump I mean that
wasn't a maybe that wasn't a possibly it
didn't take a dummy to read some of
these texts to say this dude cannot
stand yes who Trump is right well people
who are regular people sitting out there
saying dude what the hell is he doing so
you're telling me to not believe
conspiracy theories these are all the
text messages they have on what this guy
said hey uh uh January 18 2016 Martin
O'Malley's a freak Show Lisa Page yikes
baby yeah that's what we next one he
asked me to if I'd vote for yes Kasich
seriously what would you I don't know I
suppose Hillary I would be uh Paige God
Trump is a lonesome human uh he yet
human son I mean when you go through
this stuff would he be worse president
than Cruz Trump yes I think this is
public information so when you say what
you're saying as much as
the public wants to say you know what
Philip you're right man we're just
watching one too many you know
conspiracy theory movies and we just got
caught up with this YouTube stuff and
maybe we've been smoking a little too
much hash and we're getting a little too
creative but no I I don't know I I I
think there is some true hate involved
hate involved and they're targeting
certain people I think that's correct
there's there's a let me go idealistic
which which is rare for me
um I'm a realist but then go practical
idealistically when you join the
entities that I joined Peter struck did
a lot of damage to the FBI uh what
happened to him you can argue about
whether it was appropriate or not but he
did tremendous damage to the FBI the the
bottom line at the CIA and the bureau
is that most the people believe it or
not they do have strong uses these are
smart people uh the people I worked with
at the agency when I joined I got a
master's degree from a great University
the University of Virginia in English
literature my masters with defense was
in Victorian novel 19th century British
novel my Master's thesis was comparing
medieval sermons with morality plays
from you know 600 years ago I mean I sat
down with people and I said uh this is
game on
so they do have views some very strong
views you're discouraged from expressing
them in the workplace obviously these
folks on public on phones that were
given to them by the bureau which means
that's not your phone we're expressing
views during the workplace but you're
supposed to say and a lot of people did
believe it or not and I will get
realistic in a second you're supposed to
say the American people elected you know
Mary or Joe or John as president when I
go to the work to the office I wasn't
elected I served them so unless they're
doing something illegal on that ethical
or immoral that's the will of the people
and I don't represent the will of people
now let's go practical for one second
and do a numbers game and let's look at
the Russia investigation as someone who
took stats in college
stats for non-mathematicians along with
logic one of the best classes I ever
talk it trains your mind analytically
not just mathematically let's do a
numbers game let's say there are
hundreds of people involved in the
Russia investigation those people are
involved in reviewing things like who
you're going up on with informants whose
emails you're looking at how that stuff
not only is investigated in the bureau
but how it's overseen by many lawyers at
the Department of Justice what I'm
saying is statistically you start to
weed out
fringes or people who want to take the
investigation to a different place
because you simply can't go through
hundreds of people and have an
aberration you know we want to go up on
you know Adam because we don't like them
well a lawyer is going to look at that
and then 10 lawyers are going to look at
that and then it's going to be reviewed
and then the FBI director is going to
look at that and then the Attorney
General is going to look it up and
they're good or they're going to say
that's stupid and that's biased so if
you don't believe me idealistically I
just say do your stats homework and tell
me how likely it is that political bias
and investigation of several hundred
people can be or that that an
investigation of several hundred people
can be directed by one or two people who
have bias that just statistically
doesn't work well you're talking about
one-offs right like Peter shock but what
happens if it's at the top you know
whether it's a John Brennan or a
Christopher Ray or even a Robert Mueller
yeah like what kind of influence is that
person like John Brennan as an example
not a fan of trump I don't think yeah
that's correct yeah like a secret if the
person at the top has a has an agenda
how does that affect the trickle down
significant leadership and this is why
you need to pay attention you know not
to your third level uh appointments but
but to your first level appointment
Secretary of Defense Secretary of State
when you look at people like James
Madison Rex Tillerson the first people
involved in the cabinet for president
Trump you got to step back and say
like them or not these are serious
people so if you like President Trump or
you don't either way you're going to say
these people are going to provide advice
that he should listen to my experience
is that leadership even in bureaucracies
that look like they don't move are is
huge so let me give you a specific
example you look at the closeness of of
the CI leadership
pre-iraq War to the White House and
anybody who looks at history and
Georgetown the former directors director
is a friend but I think anybody who
looks at history says what are the
questions you should raise about how
distant a CI director should be from the
President George Tenet was very close to
George Bush is there a lesson that says
even though the CI is supposed to be a
obviously a fundamental support
mechanism to the White House there
should be a distance because there's a
contradiction there if you're supposed
to support the White House obviously you
should be close to them to understand
what they think what they want whether
you're supporting them properly
I think there is a balance in leadership
over time but it's not easy enough
simply to say that they should be
distant from leadership because at some
level but from the White House at some
level you have to say we're here to
serve the White House what are your
thoughts on the current leadership
what's Christopher Ray at the FBI
these ahead of the CIA forget I forget
his name again that's secret
um I know the head of the CIA some I do
not know Christopher Ray I think in my
now man 36 years of doing this
this is easily one of the best
combinations if you put if you're just
doing one plus one both of them together
that I have ever seen in terms of
experience and I look at characteristics
of leadership whether it's in the
organizations where I consult or the
Executive coaching that I do and the
characteristics I saw with people like
candy rice Colin Powell
um uh it's Bill Burns by the way Bill
Burns yeah um Mike Hayden George Tenet
uh Robert Mueller
the characteristics I see in both of
them experience
temperament humility intellectual
curiosity pure intellect how they treat
the workforce how the workforce responds
to them I think when you're looking at
leadership if you start to Define it
down in measurable areas like the areas
I just mentioned communication skills
the ability to take a bullet Chris Ray
doesn't talk much and I guarantee you
that they're at some lower level of the
people at the FBI some would say can't
you get out and defend us more which
would be a huge mistake on his part to
getting out ahead of some issues
yourself no to to raising your your head
above you know in a political Fray
Democrats and Republicans above
um The Fray because you'll get shot at
so if you stay silent he doesn't stay
silent all the time but mostly if you
stay silent the likelihood you're going
to get shot is lower keep your head in
trench both of them have these this
variety of characteristics
that is really unique I don't know Ray
but I know Burns Summit I would say
privately he's pretty funny
you can talk to him uh he's a nice guy I
mean you just don't get this this range
of people lack humility sometimes
sometimes they don't have the knowledge
they need to because they have political
connections but they don't know the
business
uh sometimes they're too political
sometimes personalities I worked with a
number of CI directors who had very
difficult personality that rude impolite
I'm like I did 15 years can you not even
say what do you think instead of kicking
my ass that's not a very good leadership
style so both of them I'd say A Plus
let's go back to this let's go back to
this because I really want to I really
want to Target this so Benghazi 30 000
emails Russia January 6 two impeachments
Mar Lago okay and Hunter Biden uh can we
also throw in 911 to that because he
said loss of life and conspiracy theory
we know we just the episode we had a few
weeks ago I'd love to get his thoughts
on that as well I'll put that as well so
let's go through some of these so uh uh
Benghazi uh uh the way we investigated
it and the level of accountability that
uh whoever was involved at that time say
Hillary Clinton uh uh was Justice served
uh based on what happened to Benghazi
and the four folks that we lost out
there
I'm not known for being subtle so let me
say yes for a basic reason you're
talking about a fairly isolated
diplomatic facilities in a hostile
country
and you want to anticipate in hundreds
of facilities overseas that you can
manage basically a mob trying to storm
that facility
if you want to make Fortress America
which if you travel overseas we already
see
you can do that these facilities are
supposed to be open to people they're
supposed to be open to Visa Seekers
but when I saw that I saw a tragedy I
saw a tragedy that should be
investigated that's why I say I agree
with an investigation that investigation
should be looking at the question of
whether there's culpability
but there's a tougher question that says
how do we balance having hundreds of
facilities so there is a there is a
both a cultural issue here about how
America wants to be perceived but
there's also a financial issue here do
you want to build fortresses in every
tiny consulate around the planet
how do you look at that and say we
should anticipate this kind of mob
coming into this kind of location and
have every place not only secured but
have a backup plan to ensure that we can
respond and evacuate I I just
we do 45 seconds on TV and um that
doesn't do a service to this problem it
goes back to the question of saying if
you want to say that Benghazi was a
Hillary Clinton problem and that we
should have responded more quickly and
prevented loss of life
spend some time making the counter
argument about how difficult difficult
it would be to plan in sub-Saharan
Africa and North Africa in the middle
east and south Asia and Southeast Asia
and East Asia for every diplomatic
location we have to plan to make sure
that never happens and I'm going to say
good luck you can't do it perfect so if
we hold that kind of accountability to
her then we have to hold a similar kind
of accountability of lack of perfection
doesn't exist anywhere which is fine we
have to stay consistent yes Fair okay so
if we're going to say Hillary's not
perfect we have to keep going with that
so 30 000 emails okay on what happened
her break in the laptops the phones all
that stuff was the was the right level
of accountability held to Hillary
Clinton for what she did and every time
they asked her questions she's like yeah
uh I don't know yeah I don't know that's
you you mentioned but earlier I'm a
political commentator I'm not I comment
on it because people ask but I I'll give
up a semi-political answer I think yes
if you look at at the information that
was in those emails it's not clear to me
that Revelation that they're revealing
that information was
hugely substantial for National Security
or could have led to loss of life so in
terms of legal responsibility I'd say I
don't know how much money the US wants
to spend on this case going back to what
I said earlier if you can anticipate a
defense attorney you can have a good
case too so we're going to spend a ton
of money and remember resources are
finite if I'm the attorney general I'm
saying man this is going to be a ton of
people how many I'd rather put those
people on child porn I'd rather put them
on gangs
the other thing though I'd say the flip
side of this is I think she paid a
tremendous price in in terms of
authenticity in turn this is where I
will make a vague political comment in
terms of people passing judgment
and to be blunt I think some of that was
appropriate when I saw some of the
answers about why this was on there what
I knew what I knew was classified and
didn't I'm like as a guy who did this
for for decades
that that dog don't hunt I thought there
was way too much bobbing and weaving way
too much avoiding questions and I
thought a lack of responsibility and
looking at a camera and don't give me
yes but yes but I didn't give me a break
anybody who deals with National Security
information knows what's going on here
if you look at some of the information
in there it is classified
sorry it is now I don't think as I said
there should have been a criminal charge
or a civil charge but I do think the
American people judged her and based on
the answers I saw I'm not saying you
should solely judge her on that basis
but people who judged her and said this
is inauthentic okay I'm with that that's
fine got it how about uh you're gonna
get is this over yet because it's not
let me know the reason why I'm going to
go through this the reason why I'm going
to go through this is because of the
same level of accountability and
softness the agency has on one side they
have to have on the other side or else
you lose credibility it doesn't matter
what it is if you're going to be gentle
uh with one and making this person well
no one's perfect well it's this well
it's that you can't go and say the other
person is evil and they're this and
they're that so the next one okay so
Hillary Clinton loses 2016 election the
world is shocked nobody watching TV
thought this was gonna happen nobody I
couldn't believe it I was at my I live
on a farm 3 30 in the morning you're
like what the hell just happened right
so I can only imagine she's in her hotel
room they're getting ready to prepare
the party the fireworks everything and
then it's announced that Trump wins
Trump shows up
for three years four years all she talks
about is you know uh the election was a
fraud there was a fraud Russia was
involved Russia was involved the
election was a fraud there's no way I
I've lost for four years but the media
allowed her to keep saying that for four
years nobody said anything should she
have every chance she got that when she
got on TV talked about that there was a
election fraud for her losing to Donald
Trump was that okay what she was doing
the answer could be yes sir and I'm okay
with it I didn't particularly care for
it I thought it was rehashing an
election that she lost that was
humiliating she lost to a candidate that
um was not the strongest candidate the
Republicans ever ever put up I mean just
just talking apolitically if you look at
polling numbers
I think a strong Democratic candidate
somebody of the caliber I'm just talking
about polling numbers and and sort of uh
reach across America
uh I she had to have been embarrassed
and I think looking around saying what
happened here for someone
I'm going to quote someone who and I
won't use the name once said uh somebody
who knows or said there are no mirrors
in the Clinton household I thought
that's a great line in other words not
looking saying maybe I maybe I wouldn't
run didn't run maybe I should have
campaigned in the Rust Belt in the
middle fair enough that's exactly right
so so uh I I think um you know the media
can put on whoever they want that's a
choice of a producer but in terms of
people to listen to to me it sounded
like sour grapes I I didn't think it did
her any favors yeah the only reason when
I say media can we do like sports or
something we're about to get into we're
about to get into some sports so a CIA
guy wants to talk sports okay but I
asked this because when he said media
can put whoever they want that's the
producer's job you're right but social
media can also choose that they want to
ban and they never banned her for kids
okay this is America this choice I don't
do Twitter I don't do fake I don't do I
have a LinkedIn account because people
sometimes
send in interesting questions or hire me
for a speech but if you if you choose to
do that you can my my as someone who
does media for a living my question is
why don't you check out if you don't
like that stuff check out go have a
glass of Cabernet go run five miles go
learn to cook check out from where what
do you mean check out from a life that
says I have to know every five minutes
what Hillary Clinton said with Donald
Trump no that's not what I'm saying what
I'm saying is actually the other way
what I'm saying is the fact that social
media companies allowed all those video
clips of Hillary saying that there was a
this was a broad election they allowed
her Clips to stay on but the other side
of the moment they said no this is uh
you know you're just talking about a
conspiracy theory so Hillary Clinton's
you know loss wasn't a conspiracy theory
but Trump's was a conspiracy theory so
which conspiracy theory is allowed and
which one's not well you're asking me
social media policy I'm gonna punt on
that one I I think the American people
give social media too much of a hard
time
if you want to sit down in Silicon
Valley and say there's billions of
tweets and I've got to figure out which
one's violent which one's semi violent
break oh no you give me a break give me
a break so these are Philip must so you
think that they should sit down an
American company that's supposed to make
money for America and like and
influences the globe yeah and go under
because they're hiring dude you think
they should you're the same guy that
said you can't put a treat me like a dog
and put a muzzle on my mouth I'm gonna
say whatever I want then you can't
silence me you said that you said that
on CNN you said this that's what I'm
saying I think they should spend less
time silencing Pika unless that's what
I'm saying unless yeah when you get into
suggesting violence and I mean
suggesting I don't mean I don't mean
asking for I think you're done I don't
think I I think you're done okay fair
enough I believe that Congress should be
saying these are American businesses
making a lot of money how do we make
their jobs more doable so then if you're
saying that to you can't put any
violence uh last week the current member
of parliament of Turkey
got up and on his Twitter account put a
video of him speaking saying if you can
find a saying hey Armenia let me remind
you guys what we did to you we're
starting to lose patience to you don't
make us if we wanted to to we can we can
choose to make you disappear off of
history and geography that's genocide
that's genocide and Twitter left it on
no he should be off oh so he should be
off in my opinion because you're
advocating violence well then that's the
part where you know the again this is
where people lose trust in organizations
who say they're fair and then the
American people say you're full of [ __ ]
you're not fair you're taking sides yeah
and that's why people are losing a
little bit of trust in different
institutions look I have four kids you
know family when he got kids they'll
come up to you and they'll say you'll
like him more and you'll like her more
and you like this more and you like that
more look I like to talk sports with my
younger son but I like to talk you know
weird topics of Science and stuff like
my oldest son I just like to hang out
with my oldest daughter because last
time we took her out because you know
Hurricane's sitting here whatever we
took her out because we took the other
guys to the Miami Dolphins game and
whatever the game was uh Buffalo Bills
sick game so she's like you're not
spending time with us we took her on a
date there's different things I like
with everybody but it's my job to try to
stay as neutral as possible whether I
agree with one of them or not right and
companies same way you have operations
operation says well sales people they
don't know [ __ ] they're breaking
everything and then sales says
operations they're so slow so that is
that is a sign of leadership and we have
a hard time doing that I think you're
exactly right I mean I mentioned
leadership before and the significance
of leadership I thought leadership would
decline in the age of social media
because people would just look at
different sources of information and
absorb them and then you realize you
know Senators members of Congress
presidents
uh Supreme Court Justices which is a
different story really still influence
people the way they should influence
people and let me give you a specific
example in a second is by saying let's
have a conversation so let's take the
wall if you're on one side you'd say the
wall keeps illegal immigrants out if
you're on the other side you say this is
a land of immigrants and this violates
the principles of what America is you
know a conversation might be let's talk
to let's talk to CBP Customs and Border
Patrol let's talk to immigration and say
are there parts of the border that are
particularly susceptible to illegal to
illegal immigrants that you have a
difficult time policing that a wall
makes sense on and so let's say there's
you know 120 miles where where experts
say yeah that would really be helpful I
would say well let's fund it there's a
compromise we're going to fund some of
the wall but we're not gonna we're gonna
not gonna fund a wall in areas where
maybe this is not that significant a
problem they're okay done we finished
that because of course you agree with me
we finished that in 30 seconds but but
what you're saying because but then the
lack of leadership is the fact that the
borders are a lady named Kamala Harris
who's the vice president refuses to go
to the border to see what's going on so
you lose again credibility you know if
you like listen what I said just a week
ago I said I have so much respect for uh
for a uh
China tells you if you go to Taiwan
we're going to do this you know she
shows up and then and you know uh
turkey says what and she shows up to
Armenia listens she's got some balls I
think she has more brass than Biden and
Kamala combined if you ask me that's
that's just but but to me is you don't
have the audacity to show up to the
Border listen of course the American
people don't believe you even even your
own side doesn't believe what you're
saying you've lost credibility
leadership is losing a lot of
credibility right now in many different
organ it's not just all the way at the
top of the White House VP
FBI it's a lot of different or
institutions and by the way I don't
think that's good you said something
very interesting uh I think you were
talking about the January 6th where you
you and lemon were going back I don't
know who was you were talking to but the
whole conversation was about the fact
that this is not a good idea the fact
that we keep pushing it the lady sitting
to your right I don't even know what she
was saying she was saying no we should
continue to push this because maybe no
more and she's saying this to the host
maybe what's going to happen is if we
keep doing this January 6 committee
Trump's going to get so upset that all
of a sudden he's gonna say something on
national television and or this was
Cuomo when Cuomo was on Euro with Como
with the girl sitting to your right and
then Como's like no that's not the right
reasons to do this and then you say I
don't think we should do this because
it's getting America to be more divided
we keep getting more divided these games
are playing well it's some of this you
know goes back to let me be a bit of a
Pollyanna I wish this shows why I will
never run for elected office you know I
think the American people I sort of have
faith in the American people will
respond to fact the fact is we have a
problem at the border now I'm a I'm not
a child I'm a child of privilege but if
you look back at you know my history
going back to the 19th century as
Italians and Irish they were not
treated well if you look and I know
American history okay if you look at how
Chinese were treated in the early 20th
century how women were treated how
blacks were treated how gays were
treated every generation discriminates
against somebody and the Next Generation
has to reverse it
and some of that's relating to
immigration people are saying immigrants
are not only bad but they're giving
American people a sense that immigrants
are dirty and every one of us I'd like
to ask a Native American what do you
think of immigrants but um the fact is
that immigration is a problem there are
too many immigrants taking advantage of
the system there's a uh I thought an
underreported story this week about how
the White House is giving more
administrative Authority
to immigration officials to reject
people I think that's part of the answer
we should be setting a far higher bar
for who gets in here and also supporting
who gets over that bar much more
aggressive you're really saying that yes
if people I wouldn't think a lot of
people would agree with you on that it
took us a long time to come to America I
went to Germany at a refuge again before
I came here we had to sacrifice uh
parents getting a divorce our entire
money that we had everything just to
come to America so I I uh I think a lot
of people in America as a as a person I
was born in Iran 10 years there two
years in Germany at a refuge Camp year
and a half that finally made it here I
value this place a ton on how long it
took us to get here it was a dream but
then but then to be clear when you get
here support for your children food and
kindergarten support for for your family
in terms of medical care there's a cost
whose job is that though I'd say partly
that it's the job of the government why
is that the government's job to educate
a child no no public school you're right
no no public school you're right but but
what is my my responsibility when I do I
do you owe me more or do I owe you more
if I come here I think both oh I
disagree I disagree how could you say
that how could you say that well how can
a person I pay a lot of taxes that
person's not going to pay a lot I just
paid a lot for them to go to school I
don't have kids wait let me get this
straight so an immigrant is wanting to
come to your house yes I want to come to
your country yes you owe me the same
amount as I owe you I owe you a lot no
no you don't know me bro that's
incorrect I I owe you I you want to
disagree you want to yell it but no
don't come across it babe I'll crush you
like a bug I'd love to see it but the
point I'm trying to make to you right
now is the following I feel I feel I owe
you
okay so that's the part where a little
bit of the mindset right now is the fact
that people are saying America owes the
Immigrant I don't agree with that I
think I think if I uh so for example
let's just say Goldman Sachs gives me an
opportunity to work for them okay if I
work for Goldman Sachs Goldman Sachs was
here before I was here I owe Goldman
Sachs for the opportunity Michael Jordan
is about the LeBron says we should
retire to number 23 permanently Michael
Jordan says listen man this league is
bigger than one player Jordan owes the
league more than the league owes Jordan
well I mean the Immigrant owes America
this whole concept about America owes
the Immigrant I never came here thinking
America owes me anything I think you're
misunderstanding me yeah I have a couple
things to say first of all to be clear
why what I said before I get well we
will get attacked from both sides I
think the bar should be higher but when
someone gets here there's a couple
things that go on to be idealistic if
you're a human being I want to give you
the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness totally good but
there's there's a brutal economic piece
and that is as someone who pays like I
say a ton of taxes without kids so I'm
paying for other kids to go to school
I'm paying for for everybody who doesn't
believe in socialism then I get to pay
the same taxes you do and I don't we
have socialism in this country and that
part of that means I pay a ton more than
you do and you use the same services
but my point is just to be purely and
brutally economic a child who goes
through a good education particularly at
the primary level if that child doesn't
have access to food I want them to have
access to food if they don't have access
to Medical Care I want them because I
want to ensure that I don't have to pay
for them in the back end to pay for
somebody if a child is educated and
healthy the chance that they'll
contribute and I'm talking about money
they're going to get a better job
they're going to be less likely to use
Public Services they're going to be less
likely in older age to be unhealthy
they're going to pay more in taxes so I
I there's a there's a brutal economic
piece to what I'm saying as well I I get
what you're saying and listen the other
day if I can find this clip man if I can
find this matter of fact if I I'm gonna
find it I'm going to have you play it uh
is so so for me this uh this lady
a judge is talking to this other person
who her husband and her are getting the
divorce and the judge asks her about
what she's gonna do for you know finding
a job making I'll find it here we'll
post it in a minute I think the the the
concept of what you're saying is public
schools being offered to immigrants
totally fine of course you know they
take them of course yeah you chose to
let him in of course
but I think it's going back to this one
guy named John who got assassinated in
the 60s who was beloved by people around
the world and in America what was this
guy's name John no he had a middle name
Fitzgerald last name was Kennedy right I
was talking to his uh uh nephew
yesterday uh uh excited about what he's
working on but uh you know you've heard
this I'm not the first person that's
saying sharing this quote it's been
shared a billion times you know don't
ask what your country can do for you ask
what you know what you can do for your
country I think it's more we got to kind
of go back to that Hey listen guys like
what are you doing for America okay yeah
I think we're and this is where
conversation helps I you got to get a
job you can't go on the Dole there's you
know if I were a king I'd say there's a
lot yes yes that's it we're on the same
page but but I don't but we've
encouraged people to say immigrants are
dirty immigrants and so yeah
oh come on you don't think there's a
sentiment oh oh I don't no I'm talking
about that let me see what he's going to
say I don't Mexican rapist Mexicans are
rape no those who are rapists that
they're sending their rapists here yeah
we shouldn't have him here yes I agree
with that okay you know the the most
like you know Bill Maher said something
very interesting when you were on with
him and Bill Maher said to your face
Bill Maher said most Muslims are not
terrorists but most terrorists are what
Muslims yeah he said that do you and and
your sinner said okay how do you and you
didn't argue that you're like that
that's right okay so but for for for for
for you to say you were saying that uh
you know immigrants are rapists give me
a break you don't think people have more
of an anti-immigrant sentiment today
than they would have 30 years ago no I
don't okay I disagree I don't and I'm an
immigrant I'm the Immigrant talking I'm
not a white guy that's privileged I grew
up in a family that went to Vanderbilt
and has got you know lived in a nice
Community that's not this guy I'm the
Immigrant listen let me tell you when I
experience discrimination and I'll give
it to you when I was in the Army and I'm
shooting a rifle it's a funny story but
it's a true story
I'm shooting a rifle and I got the M16
on my nose my drill sergeant comes and
says I've never seen a nose like that in
my life before he says where are you
from I said I'm from Iran and he says
man that's a massive note I said I
appreciate it I said drill Serge I got
to tell you something he says what's
that I said it'll take me seven thousand
dollars to make my nose look like yours
it'll take you Millions to make yours
look like mine right it starts cracking
up we have a relationship together I go
to Alabama I'm at a waffle house 1997.
I'm going to Panama City to party at
Club La Villa and spinnakers apparently
Club level is going out of business
right now or they went out of business
on the way there to Alabama I sit there
at the Waffle House
everyone's white waitress shows up
she keeps looking at me like she's never
seen a creature like this before
and I said ma'am is there something
going on you're okay sir where are you
from Sam from Iran you from Iran Iran
she says where'd you run she says yes
I'm Ryan I said yes I'm from Iran she
says uh what are you doing here in
Alabama I said I'm in your army I'm in
the U.S army they let you in the US Army
yes
what are you doing in the US Army I said
can I feel comfortable telling you she
says yeah of course I said I'm a spy I'm
taking all your content and I'm taking
them back to Iran to train our soldiers
so that a little bit of that happens
yeah but to sit there and say oh my God
I'm a victim feel sorry for me give me a
break and Adam's gonna police this what
I said was I think there's more
anti-American cinnamon today than 30
years ago yes or no you did say that but
but you also said that every generation
we have to kind of Trace back and and
fulfill what happened in the prior
generation before that yes talked about
you being Italian Irish immigrant the
Jews and the blacks yeah everything
that's happened since that but the
sentiment that you're talking about are
you basically saying because you went
off on Trump with the [ __ ] comments
right yeah [ __ ] whole country is that
what you're referring to you're saying
that the sentiment against immigrants
is that where you're going with this
yeah I mean I can't look ahead far
enough to say where people will judge us
in the future I can guess based on
history they'll judge us for something
though in terms of how we treated people
maybe how we treated immigrants I don't
know I'm not comfortable with the with
the with the rhetoric I see about anger
immigration in this country I would say
the rhetoric have to be has to be more
fact-based because we're going back to
where you started the conversation both
sides should say we have a problem and
that problem goes back to the Congress
to say the laws should allow more rapid
and more sort of dispersed decision
making about whether a 19 year old who
wants a job should be allowed across the
border and my answer is no
you know statement to you so you know uh
I've been to restaurants where it's
packed 24 7. you go there okay and then
you'll go on Yelp and you'll read a
review this restaurant sucks the owner
is terrible their customer service is
horrible they're gonna go out of
business
and I'll be in the restaurant I'm like
dude if this review was right why the
hell am I in line for 20 minutes
what the hell is going on with this
restaurant that's supposed to be the
worst restaurant in the world if America
treats immigrants so bad why did we have
a record-breaking two million people
came through the border for so horrible
at immigrants if we're so terrible at
treating immigrants what do you think
you could stop twisting my comments I
did not say we traded immigrants poorly
I think we if you look at things like
access I wish we could rewind this thing
I said people's thinking and attitudes
about immigrants has changed to the
negative because people like you keep
saying it oh for God's sakes because we
keep saying okay we're perfect to them
I just have one question because we're
pro-immigration here correct illegal
immigration we all came from my family
were Russian Jews who came over the
bolshik revolution you came over in 1992
after the Iranian Revolution you said
that your family right 1990 sorry your
family came over I don't know wherever
yeah yeah okay but you're saying that
there should be certain qualifications
that we want the best the best the best
the brightest but isn't that
antithetical to what is that literally
written on the Statue of Liberty what
does it say in a Statue of Liberty give
me your your tired give me your poor
give me your huddled masses give me your
homeless those aren't exactly the
brightest Minds out there these are poor
refugees immigrants who are coming here
for political Asylum to escape what is
going on in other countries yes so
what's the deal with that it I think it
goes back to to the problem we have
about conversations in Congress
especially with ease of movement in the
21st century
to sit there and say that everybody who
because they're poor wants access to
America means that over time
the ability to observe absorb poor will
decline you can't overwhelm the system
so the conversation in Congress has to
be there has to be a balance between
saying we live by the standards of
America and that might be a numerical
judgment that is we can absorb X number
of people that's a legal judgment that
means some people who might be qualified
aren't going to get in because we can't
absorb that many but I go back to saying
Democrats and Republicans can't sit down
and say we have a problem on the
Democrat side it has to say we need to
have limitations it may lead to
adjustments in law on the Republican
side it has to mean that we're going to
allow a fair number of people here who
are going to live off the system for a
while because they don't have that many
skills maybe they come from a place
where they're oppressed I just I just go
back to saying I wish we could have
realistic conversations among
professionals instead of saying you know
both tribes Democrats and Republicans
say not only are they the adversarial
party what we're increasingly saying is
they are the enemy and they don't
represent American values that's in the
past I don't know decade or two and that
is corrosive one more Point here
regarding skills all right I'm born and
raised in Miami I can't tell you how
many Uber drivers I run into waiters I
run into I said oh how long you've been
driving Uber oh you know two years oh
where are you from uh Colombia Venezuela
Cuba pick a country oh what'd you do
there oh I was a doctor what yeah okay
oh I was an engineer what right so you
talk about skills you're talking about
people who are of higher pedigree of
other countries that show up here and
they're just happy just because they're
in a freaking America and they're
they're okay driving an Uber now
obviously they want to make more of
their life they want to do more than
that but
yeah there's a there's sort of a Tipping
Point here where it's like you might be
a highly skilled doctor yeah in
Venezuela but now you're an Uber driver
in Miami how do you grapple that and
Pat's point I think that shows that that
proves my point we want to ensure that
we maintain some sort of standards of
immigration where people like that still
see opportunity
and at some point I would be afraid that
if we flood the system there will be
fewer opportunities our ability to take
care of not take care of but to allow
for an opportunity for an immigrant will
decline which is sort of I guess half a
republican argument
um
I I still think this is a great place
for people to come I mean I look at my
work this has been an acrimonious for
the past 10 minutes mostly your fault
Pat but I but I look at my job Phoenix
sensibilities
growing up in um Coral Gables I fished
in the canals of Coral Gables you grew
up in Coral Gables Coral Gables yes
South Miami of course I um I played
Little League Baseball I rode around my
bike you know we played in the park and
Mom said come home when the lights go on
I look at my childhood and you don't
know it when you're a child but man what
an idyllic life I don't know where you
could live uh and I I mean I lived in
Paris for a while okay let's take Paris
off the table
but uh I'd look at that and say boy I
hope every immigrant and every American
gets that opportunity it was awesome I
never caught anything but that wasn't
the point it was a lot of fun to come
down here so let's let's wrap this up
before we go let's wrap this up January
6th how much credibility is behind what
they did with you know every day on the
on TV watching and selection and
selection insurrection
and I got two more and then we're
wrapped up
um
not wrapped up with the whole episode
just wrapped up with this segment
correct yeah we'll wrap them again
it's giving me hope that we're right
it's like I need to go we got one more
hour Phil well
as they say it's 12 o'clock somewhere I
know you're used to 45 second uh
segments on CNN we go two hours here
babe
um January 6th was it was it a uh you
know uh [ __ ] show they're just trying to
you know make it look like bigger than
it really is or was it uh credible that
they waste a lot of time and money were
they trying to divide was it a good idea
was it not a good idea I think the
investigation that the doj investigation
into the individuals who went over into
the Congress is worthwhile it's hugely
it may be the biggest investigation
they've ever ever conducted in terms of
the number of people
you're looking at and who were involved
if you wrap in election denial I think
the political investigation is worth it
because the prospect that people will go
into a future election and do the same
thing I think is
is worrisome I I tend not to be sort of
the sky is falling but I would not want
to encourage people to say it's now
acceptable political rhetoric to say the
election was stolen for me and Mitch
McConnell supporting legislation that
sort of changes the game on this I think
is an indicator there are people on both
sides of the aisle a little bit worried
about attitudes in America on elections
election denial
that's different from how culture dealt
with it I think it it once again divided
culture into saying we ought to
immediately prosecute people in the
White House
try that trial can you show me
consistently how all these people told
somebody to go break a law and break a
criminal statute or do you think that
I thought the coverage encouraged people
to say this is the only thing that's
important in America right now it's
important but there's I if there's a lot
of other things going on it's not the
top thing I worry about
um so I thought some of the
investigative work was valuable
especially in terms of not only holding
people accountable but looking forward
and saying how do we change laws to
ensure that election denial isn't part
of the American political culture in
terms of cultural coverage
I'm like this is like whoa this is
overwhelming too much too much okay how
about how about the two impeachments
uh I thought I'm going to say this again
I thought the investigation that Robert
Mueller conducted was
serious and worthwhile as someone who
did
foreign policy for a lifetime suggesting
that it's okay to encourage foreign
powers Russia or others to inject
information into an American election
that is just
that's needs to be investigated
people who attacked Mueller for not
filing charges including people that I
knew at the FBI who who were on
Mueller's team Mueller was the most
straightforward
the best leader I ever saw in government
he looked at this and said again you got
to look at both sides of this argument I
don't I'm not sure that we should we
should or can prosecute these cases so
worth investigating but I thought
Mueller's decision was entirely
defensible in terms of coverage man
again we made it the only thing people
talked about in the midst of serious
conversations we should be having about
why our educational standards are modest
in this country educational or uh Health
Care in this country is excellent access
is still compared to our peer countries
okay life expectancy is dropping things
like obesity and diabetes you know you
might call me again a Pollyanna but if
you want to talk about stuff that
affects an American citizen
Health Care affects an American citizen
a lot more than a Russian impeachment
will so I thought the process was
appropriate the attention was a bit much
in terms of the the final the second
impeachment I thought that was an
egregious abuse of Presidential Power to
ask a foreign leader to investigate a
rival son I think Hunter Biden is worthy
investment investigation that is some
dirty stuff but you can't have
presidential authorities um pressing the
president pressing a foreign leader to
conduct a political investigation
against a criminal investigation against
a rival that's a no you can't do it you
can't do that so so when Obama did it
and he got caught recorded I'll do it
after the election he shouldn't have
done that either he should be
investigated today that's what you're
saying I I this I don't remember you you
don't remember when Obama said when he's
talking on National Television he got
recorded saying we can first let's get
this election knocked out of the way
then we'll address that
no
I'm talking about with Russia yeah with
Russia and uh the invasion of Crimea
yeah I mean I was like it's fun like I
don't know what channel you watch if you
didn't see well I can kind of see what
channel you watch if you didn't I know
you just made an assumption that's done
I don't I don't have a TV yeah but this
this right here was
on a hot mic he gets caught this by the
way this this is the problem this is the
problem that we have and not in this
you're not saying you're the problem the
problem that we have is the fact that
the if if a guy like you your background
a CIA
an FBI and you didn't see this and this
was all over television time out time
out
a president asked a a country overseas
to conduct an investigation to a
political rival
is are you saying that's what this is
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute do you want to go to what Biden
did when he told the Ukraine guy what
he's going to do do like if you played
this card You're Gonna Lose a lot again
this is the part why I'm doing this some
people are watching this and they're
saying Pat we don't give a [ __ ] why are
you doing it I'm not doing it for you
I'm doing it for me here's why I'm doing
it stay consistent is all I'm saying
because because to to the left Trump is
to the left what Hillary is to the right
okay yeah let's just kind of put that
put it there for me if I'm gonna go hard
at someone I have to go hard on the
other one as well that maybe he's on my
side well unless they're not equivalent
oh so so to you to you between the two
I'm assuming the lesser of the two evil
to you is Hillary
man you're not I'm doing facts did
someone ask a leader of a of another
country to conduct a criminal
investigation against the child if you
if we do that I can bring a million and
one different things that Biden has done
and Obama's done and show it to you and
then what are you gonna say so this is a
conversation about give me space on
missile defense and you want to say
that's the same as asking do you want me
to pull up with Biden tool the guy that
here's what we're going to want you to
answer the question I just asked you are
you saying this is equivalent or not I I
think every one of them at the same
level if you're asking for a favor that
will do this afterwards it should be
held at the same level I disagree if the
favor is about a diplomatic conversation
that doesn't involve a political rival I
see that as diplomacy now you might not
like the diplomacy but that's not what
so so let me let me ask you this why why
the infatuation with Ukraine all of a
sudden with U.S why
this why why are we why are we all of a
sudden so so Iran on the other end you
know people are there getting killed
plummeted you know they're getting
crushed they're getting destroyed and
our attention is only on Ukraine we're
not thinking about that why are we doing
what we're doing with Ukraine and not
some of the other places you know how
many American people are sitting there
saying oh so when he said that and the
link between the Sun and Ukraine and
himself in the past all this stuff that
pulled up in the New York Post story was
hidden and then afterwards Mark
Zuckerberg said that I was talking in
communication with FBI which he probably
didn't even think he just said that and
then you know the story of Pfizer
announces the uh vaccine is ready three
days after the election is over with all
of this stuff you're sitting there
watching saying listen man I have a hard
time believing what the hell is going on
here now I see what's going on with
Ukraine you have to understand the same
way when you say the conspiracy
theorists from both sides the left's got
its own conspiracies that they follow
like Hillary said the election was a
fraud yeah for three four years all I'm
saying is if you're gonna say that we
have to stay consistent we can only see
we can only see when when people were
saying Trump Russia Russia Russia I said
hey
if you think that's the case prove it I
don't know this recent guy that went
viral Tate who's all over the place do
you know what Tate did I said listen
there's a big difference between you
know breaking the law and offending
people that's correct if he offended you
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if you I'm
offended on a daily basis if he broke
the law that's got to go with the court
I have no control over that I don't have
the investigation so when a Russia thing
took place well Trump trump Adam Schiff
okay if that's the I don't have access
to that do your job and prove it right
that's right and then three years later
Durham comes out this was adasia paid
for Hillary 35 million American people
now you're not no longer talking about a
CNA you just got forgot about Russia and
for three and a half years that's all
you guys ever talked about what happened
oh you guys excuse me I'm not you're
talking to Philip no you're not talking
you guys being CNN is what I'm saying
too I'm a contractor for CNN I'm not an
employee I go and speak what I say I
attack president Trump I've said
negative things about Hillary Clinton so
I'm not here as a spokesman for CNN all
I'm saying is all I'm saying is when
you're talking about
uh holding one side to the fire we have
to hold all sides to the fire if we're
gonna do that we have to stay consistent
that's all I'm saying well CNN is
clearly paying the price for having an
agenda and being biased and not holding
both sides accountable I think what you
said is there's there is a major
difference between fact and feelings
right so Trump pissed off a lot of
freaking people that doesn't mean that
he was a criminal I'm not saying that
he's not a criminal that needs to be
proven that's not my job though right my
job isn't to prove that if that's if if
the lady in New York what's her name
Leticia James if if her in New York she
wants to file the lawsuit the court of a
billion dollars towards uh Trump and you
know lose licensing guess what hey it
sucks but guess what you know they can
do that and then you can come back and
make the argument you're gonna have to
spend a lot of money on legal fees so
maybe that's a way of getting them to
spend a lot of money on legal fees and
she did campaign on the fact that if you
elect me I'm gonna sue the Trump family
yeah she get the promise I mean that's
like you know and there's where but
politicians and and this is one one
problem with the American political
culture where people involved in in
um and civil and criminal cases are
elected politicians who argue for during
a campaign that somebody should be
prosecuted to me is
that's something that should be
borderline illegal suggesting that
somebody whether it's Donald Trump or
Hillary Clinton should be locked up
should be the Judgment of people at the
Department of Justice
those people should be separate as they
are or are supposed to be if you look at
at Bill Maher for example from the White
House and political pressure we have
gotten way too comfortable in this
country with people saying not only do I
not like my adversary I said this 10
minutes ago but my adversary is an enemy
to America and they should be in in a
jail that's third world lock her up that
is yeah or saying again that the people
who too quickly say Mar-A-Lago he should
he should be charged right well that's a
legal process that should have involved
fact by professionals not politicians
and I object to the January 6 committee
saying I want to make referrals they
should not be telling the depart like
the Department of Justice doesn't have
an investigation and know how to look at
an investigation in facts as soon as you
make a referral one you're saying
politicians think something should
happen and as soon as the Department of
Justice moves and I don't think the
January 6th committee has thought about
this enough somebody on the right is
going to say you're doing that because
because Congress told you to not because
that's a good case I think January 6
ought to do their own investigation and
say nothing to Department of Justice
Beyond here are some documents if you
want them can I just ask one quick
question simple question and just very
simple uh Trump okay
um I have a lot of conversations with
people wildly different opinions on
Trump okay so people on the left
literally think he's the devil
reincarnated he's the worst person
that's ever lived lived he's evil like
the worst the worst the worst the worst
and the people on the right I'm talking
about Fringe elements people on the
right
literally the next Messiah greatest
president we've ever had in U.S history
George Washington Abraham Lincoln don't
hold a candle to Trump talk about French
French
um clearly there's some Middle Ground
there he's I don't think either one of
those I want you to put on your complete
unbiased hat you've been covering Trump
since you know forever where do you
genuinely think Trump stands he's not
evil he's not a messiah where's Trump I
look at uh in my relatively short
lifetime I was born in 1961 some of the
people who showed characteristics of
leadership in my lifetime LBJ Kennedy I
thought in some way and Jimmy Carter who
I did not think was a great president
but has some has leadership
characteristics Ronald Reagan George H.W
bush has a man of great humility a lot
of wisdom I thought a courteous man a
thoughtful man a curious man which I
think is important for a president
um if you look at the defining this by
characteristics of leadership
intellectual curiosity experience
humility ability to deal with an
adversary and and Rise Above The Fray I
don't see those characteristics in
president Trump I'm looking for a
characteristic that would lead me to say
to someone in a poli-sci class or to a
nine-year-old you should emulate that
characteristic and I'm including
characteristics personal characteristics
like temperament
like courtesy like kindness like
humility I just didn't see him I I don't
disagree with you but isn't that why he
was elected because he wasn't the
traditional political figure he's a
businessman he grew up in the Rough and
Tumble streets of New York he had to
make it isn't there something to be said
about that I do but I I think that's
because
um politicians have encouraged Americans
to have started to say if I take
Americans down which is easier than
taking them up if I take Americans down
I can win votes
by taking him down I'm saying you can
sit there and tell people that person's
evil that person's your enemy that
person does things that are un-American
as opposed to looking at the country as
Reagan did as LBJ did and saying I can
go to a higher place which sometimes
means telling people things they don't
want to hear
The Shining City on a Hill correct yes
which I you know I talked about my
childhood I'd lived on a shining City on
a Hill it was awesome my childhood I
wish my dad and mom were around they're
not
I would tell them once again I loved
them I didn't tell them enough they just
did me a tremendous favor by the
environment I had in the education I had
I think that's a good reminder for
everyone out there to just tell your
parents you love them so so listen I
appreciate you for going through this uh
with me while I'm going back known
stories I'd still be in DC but that's
okay well this is how we do we all of a
sudden I've seen you do it way worse
than that you know you know if people
come to this show they kind of know
we're going to talk and it's a long form
you get a chance to talk we get a chance
to give arguments and I think at the end
of the day the audience wins and that's
what the outcome is there's a few topics
I do want to talk about that's more
current I want to talk about Iran what's
going on there I do want to talk about
uh the uh the uh North uh stream
pipeline what's going on there the whole
comment from the PM of uh Poland
sabotage and that's some very very
interesting stuff and then a few other
topics that we may hit up here that we
have but prior to doing that I want to
give a shout out to our sponsor Aura uh
Aura is somebody that we uh decided to
team up with a couple months ago for
specific reason I've been in the
financial industry now for 20 some years
every meeting I'm going to right now all
they're talking about is cyber security
cyber security cyber security our amount
of money we've spent in cyber security
the last year has gone up every single
year cyber security is officially the
number one crime cyber crime is
officially the number one crime uh
effective 2021 ahead of home robbery one
and a half million incidents last year
nearly 52 billion dollars
of losses to American people just last
year because of cyber attacks and it's
not slowing down it's just getting more
and more and I think a lot of people
when they see this they're kind of like
well it's like selling Insurance power
why do I need insurance I'm only 32
years old nobody thinks they need
insurance until they find out they have
cancer unless they realize somebody in
their family is about to lose their life
and then you sit there and say man I
wish I had Insurance just trust me I've
gone through this many times we had our
guys go on or and run a test for
themselves on the dark web one of our
guys Aaron had 40 of his passwords on
the dark web and that's what Aura does
when it comes down to fraud every second
matters connect your credit bank
accounts and get notified of any changes
up to four times faster than Ora's
competitors their VPN allows you to stay
anonymous online by keeping your
browsing history and personal
information safe and encrypted and their
antivirus software will block malware
and viruses before they infect your
videos protect you and yourself from
America's fastest growing crime try Aura
free for two weeks and see if any of
your or your family's personal
information has been compromised you can
start your 14-day trial today at
aura.com forward slash pbd once again
aura.com forward slash pbd Aura is
spelled
a-u-r-a.com forward slash p b d we'll
put the link below in the description
and chat for you to go out there and
take advantage of so having said that
let's go into uh I want to do North
stream uh pipeline I think this is more
current and it's a little bit concerning
because this some are saying could be
the Tipping Point to uh War meaning the
nuclear war that uh may be there whether
we're there or not I don't know but let
me share three stories from you one is
from Insider the other the other one's
from the post-millennial and another
one's from The Insider so first one
German lawmakers break Europe silence on
suspect suspected North stream pipeline
Saboteur Saboteur to point the finger at
Russia on Tuesday Swedish and danish
authorities reported three leaks on the
pipelines running under the Baltic Sea
from Russia to Germany two in North
stream one and another node stream to
the two senior German lawmakers that
pointed a finger at Russia over suspect
the sabotage of Nordstrom natural gas
pipelines Roderick Keys weather a
government spokesperson for Christ
Crisis Prevention said that the attack
was an act of sabotage by Russia to
deter and threaten Europe Mary Agnes
struck Zimmerman Sherman uh chairwoman
of the bundestag defense committee also
named Russia in comments and suspect
that attacked the CIA warned Germany
when weeks ago about potential attacks
on North stream very weird CIA is saying
hey we have a feeling someone's gonna
attack it's a little weird for me there
that you're like a Houdini type of
situation so uh uh uh not Houdini
Nostradamus type of situation so next
one European official says sabotage
likely cause of suspicious North stream
leaks so that's a post-millennial uh uh
Danish Prime Minister mete Frederickson
noted that while it is too early to
conclude whether the incidents were Act
of sabotage there are three leaks and
therefore it is difficult to imagine
that it could be accidental polish prime
minister matus morawiki said we don't
know all the details of what happened
but we can clearly see that it's an act
of sabotage to make a he's not even
saying maybe he said we can clearly uh
see that it's an act of sabotage related
to The Next Step of escalation of the
situation in Ukraine and last but not
least the same story again comes with
some of the commentary uh where the
reporter said but will you uh when Joe
Biden was asked February 7th I'll read
this on what happened between Joe Biden
when this question was asked it's pretty
intense
President Joe Biden on February 7th
promised to prevent Nordstrom 2 from
begin becoming operational if Russia
invaded Ukraine he said if Russia
invades then there will be no longer a
North stream too we will bring an end to
it reporter asked but how will you do
that exactly since the project is in
Germany's control Biden I promise you we
will be able to do that that's seven
months ago so based on what you've been
following this story with and where
you're at what are your thoughts on what
the hell is going on with North stream
one and two who's behind it
the one of the earliest victims in times
of tension is is the difference between
what I think and what I know and one of
the things I learned at the agency is
man be very careful about Crossing that
line I think the White House has been
more cautious since some of the people
in Europe
who spoke
I think Russia did this basically
because you're looking at multilateral
Warfare and we Define Warfare in terms
of kinetic I put bombs on something I
put artillery on something clearly going
into the winter with Europe that's
dependent on on gas from Russia it you
would say on the surface why would
Russia want to sabotage pipelines where
they're making money they want to tell
Europe this is very simple they want to
tell Europe when it gets cold
uh and you need to heat homes careful
where your we're your source and if
Nordstrom 2 comes on we're going to
continue to be your source and this is
what can happen if you guys don't
um sort of continue to import and also
don't back off on Ukraine so I think
Russia did it but you know that's what I
think that's not what I know I would
want to have basic questions for example
technical questions when do we get
overseas drones so we can see how these
things were sabotaged can Engineers tell
me what the causes of those sabotage
might have been as a non-expert I'm not
my my degrees in English literature I
want to know what exactly happened and
whether that could be explained by
natural means or whether it an engineer
can guarantee to me that that's an
external
um that's an external event that was
manipulated by a human being so I think
Russia did it I think the reasons are
pretty basic I think Biden over promised
I'd close by saying this is where
foreign policy is interesting one of the
things that fascinated me in
three-dimensional for example there's
got to be a lot of conversations and
these include people like the Saudis a
lot of conversations about energy
Security in Europe going on 10 years
you know that's where Anthony Anthony
blinken's involved here's a really
interesting conversation I would
have liked to participate in if I were
still in let's anticipate that that
Putin will stay aggressive over the
course of time what are we learning
about vulnerabilities of Russian forces
in Ukraine how do we push NATO without
additional American backing to say we
want to
forward deploy in places like the
Balkans in Poland to take advantage of
those Russian vulnerabilities if Russia
does there's a lot of planning going on
here and I think North the the the the
the gas pipeline is the part of it is
part of it because you are guaranteeing
that Russians are that the Europeans
realize they're under threat so now is
the time to go in and talk to them and
say we better prepare for the next
threat and we don't know if that's
Balkans we don't know if it's Poland but
be careful of baltics not Balkans quick
follow-up by the way I completely
appreciate what you say about what you
think versus what you know I think
that's something we could all kind of
take away from this episode is like you
might think something but you don't know
for sure
exactly I mean America oh my God too
many times it's such a powerful comment
right there uh just quick question what
are the chances that the U.S actually
did this you know what is that number is
it one percent is it five percent what
is that zero zero you don't think that
but but again let me be for people who
say you know you're just you're just
supporting the government if you do that
you're gonna have to have an executive
order that executive order is gonna have
to go through a chain of command you're
gonna have to not have a number of
people who are involved in the actual
sabotage operation so going to my
college stats class yeah what's the
likelihood that not one of them has or
will ever speak that's you you if you're
doing the multiplication numbers that's
just not possible I never saw a secret
that didn't get out nothing we did that
I can remember I'm sure there's some
minor things but the major operations we
ran I can't think of any that didn't get
out fair enough and then regarding
Russia I don't not I'm not the Nordstrom
guy but I I do understand supply and
demand and imports exports if they're
making money from Europe now they're not
going to be able to make money because
these these uh Nordstrom won't be
working Europe's still going to import
energy and oil from other countries now
they're going to go to Saudi or they're
going to go to even America or they're
going to go to Iran or they're going to
go to Venezuela whoever's you know
pumping out oil doesn't that just kind
of shoot themselves in the foot if
you're Russia but I think if this is
where the job I used to have which is
basically uh understanding the World
Through The Eyes of an adversary to
avoid that the analytic phrases to avoid
mirror Imaging don't think the opponent
sees the world the way you do the
adversary even the person you're just
negotiating with
my what I think not what I know but what
I think is that and Putin is almost as
much as said this is that his priority
is the restoration of the Russian Empire
I mean he talks about the decline of the
Soviet Union and the end of the Soviet
Union is one of the biggest tragedies of
the 20th century so if your priority is
geopolitical and let's restore sort of a
Zara State and and the the cost is
economic pain for a few years I can see
him prioritizing I want to restore
basically the Empire and if it costs us
you know a couple of difficult years a
difficult decade I have a bigger Vision
that goes it's like the al-Qaeda guys
used to tell me I know this sounds like
a strange parallel but I'll never never
forget it
they used to look at us in
interrogations and one of them said once
you know you think of life in terms of
years
this the the caliphate may not happen in
my lifetime
maybe not my kids but it might happen in
my grandchildren's lifetime Americans
don't think like that right but some of
our adversaries do
we have a YOLO mentality here they've
got a legacy of mentality so so go ahead
partly because life is so good here Pat
what was the the quote that you've
referenced before uh you guys may have
all the watches but we have all the time
I believe is that what they said about
yeah yeah the Taliban I believe so so
okay so let's let's process this on on
what we're saying uh that Russia's
behind this and some are saying us is
behind us it's really the two main
parties that people are saying is behind
this is Russia or U.S okay he said zero
us but so clearly we know based on what
we 100 percent know not what we're
speculating what we 100 know to take
your argument we know that the the
person in charge his name is Joe Biden
said if Russia invades then there will
be no longer a North stream too we will
bring it to an end so the only thing we
know for a fact is that only one person
in the world out of 7.7 billion people
only said this Putin didn't say there's
only one person said it and it's the
leader of the Free World the president
of the United States said this okay can
we find that and then and then not just
to quote the video yeah some said you
can find a quote Yeah okay and then the
reporter says but how will you do that
exactly since the project is in
Germany's controlled Biden this is what
we know not what we think I promise you
we will be able to do that okay so now
let me go to the other part so for me
um
if you can find this clip somewhere it
was on February 7th 22. it's easy to
find it's not hard it's all over the
place here's the other part uh again I'm
going based on what we know not what we
think and not what I'd like to if this
is the one just played so the audience
can see it because it's not just a it's
exactly what I'm
the border of Ukraine again then uh
there will be uh we there will be no no
go back go back go back go back from the
beginning so they can hear the whole
thing if Russia invades uh that means
tanks or troops crossing the uh the the
border of Ukraine again then uh there
will be uh we there will be no longer on
North stream too he said we will be
February okay this is listen how will
you do that
the lady's confused exactly since the
project and control of the project is
within Germany exactly we will
I promise you we'll be able to do it
okay so so can you commit today turning
off and pulling the plug on Nordstrom
too you didn't mention it you haven't
mentioned it you can pause it as much as
you can watch okay so so this we know so
the the people that may debate the
argument that it's really Russia are
going to say where's your proof because
this is proof and your leader said this
this is a threat and we did it we did
invade Ukraine so guess what if the
person that said they're gonna do the
Tim so we can't say zero percent that's
my opinion on the we can't say zero
percent so now let me go to the other
part
on Nordstrom 2 pipeline we have to look
at who owns most of it right if I own a
company
and I have leverage over you and if I
hurt the company that I'm the majority
owner of I'm an idiot I'm a qualified
idiot I'm not a strategist I'm not a Sun
Tzu guy I'm not a uh you know one of the
greatest generals of all time I'm a
qualified [ __ ] if I hurt the company
that I have control over and I lose
leverage specifically this kind of
Leverage we're not even talking about
like company free enterprise capitalism
this is like Leverage at the highest
level of Leverage where you get to
control the world you know Europe
specifically where their winter is
coming so let's see who owns majority of
North stream pipeline if you can kind of
show the shareholders here and zoom in
go a Little Bit Closer Closer Closer
Closer Closer Closer a little bit more
closer so 51 is owned by gas prom so
let's see who is God's prom
they're the largest supply of natural
gas in the world accounting for
approximately 15 of world's gas
production it was established as a joint
stock company in 1993 and partly owned
by the Russian State over 50 percent
interesting core activities include
exploration production Transportation
you can read the rest of it if you want
to do it number two is another company
called winter shawl D 15.5 now this
company with a merger of winter Shaw
holding agnd8 Deutsche German or adult
AG two successful companies what a long
tradition have formed Europe's leading
independent natural gas and oil company
huh okay cool let's look at the next one
the third company is Eon aeon Eon PG
infrastructure AG this is an
International investor-owned Energy
company which focused on energy networks
and customer Solutions as one of
Europe's largest energy companies but
it's not really one place it's all over
the place
it's a German company next one Envy uh
Netherland uh gasoline okay nine percent
so as I I can keep going on and go to
the next one NG by people of you know
this next one is a base that of a you
can see which one is this one as well
anyways but the point is 51 is Russia
so if you
caused this in your Russia you will go
down in a history books
as the biggest idiot of all time for
giving up the leverage that you have
during a time like this so if a lawyer
wanted to make a case simply to a better
because he's going to go in Las Vegas
and bet over a 30-year bet because
eventually CI is going to leak this in a
movie and we're going to watch an Argo
in 2052 that's going to say Biden was
really behind us and we're going to say
no [ __ ] and I'm 74 years old did you see
that I'll be dead so at this space
you're probably going to be alive
because we're living a long time today
but but but the point is this is pretty
creepy for the people are that are
saying U.S could have done it because
there is documentation and proof that
U.S could be behind this what do you say
to those crazy conspiracy theorists
I'd give them a pretty simple answer
which is let's go back to fact right now
we're making judgments based on no
access or very little access to the
places where there's damage we said it's
either Russia or or the United States
I'm not an engineer but you took one off
the table that I would not take off the
table because it's not a fact people say
there's no way this is this is some kind
of industrial accident I'm like how can
you tell me that if you haven't had
access to the places where the event
happened so first of all getting back to
the earlier point the President should
never have said that because we don't
own this the Americans like to say we
can snap our fingers and do stuff the
Europeans and the Russians
he shouldn't say he thought a person was
alive in two days he can't deliver on
this but my point is I would say and
this is this is why time sort of
attention spans in America are difficult
the right answer is like the right ass
around the Russian investigation let's
look at some facts and when we gather
those facts including undersea access to
the locations where this happened we
will draw conclusions about what
happened and start reacting to it
but saying we're going to do XYZ based
on no at no definitive answer about what
happened I don't get this I mean I get
it politically you have to give the
American people an answer but
analytically you don't have a fact so
you just jump from what I think to what
I know and you're going to base policy
on that I I don't not me I'm an analyst
I wouldn't do that I'm just analyzing
what my president said yeah so going
back I have to follow my president
because my president publicly with a
microphone in front of him he's the guy
that's my president he's your he's our
president right he said if they invade
Ukraine we will shut it down the lady
said how exactly when you don't have
control over it he says trust me well
he's he's wrong he doesn't matter
whether he's right or wrong but he said
it though that's a fact yes he it does
matter because it doesn't matter whether
he's right around because he can't do
this the right answer is the difficult
answer that is you go to the Europeans
and you go to the to the non-russians
who have peace is not only of the
pipeline but also have to deal with heat
during the winter and say
we have to have a long-term solution
which is alternate access and we have to
have a short-term solution which is what
do you want to do in November and if we
think we can tell them your your people
are going to be called we don't give a
[ __ ] because the president said we're
going to shut it down American arrogance
at play the first question is to the
Europeans who all probably also have
better ideas than we do because they
have to deal with this every day they
know what political opinion is they know
what the attitudes of populations who
have to be cold is what do you think we
should do and let's start maybe taking
somebody else's lead once so a little
humility let's let's go through some
case study okay
Pearl Harbor happens FDR gets up and
says they're going to pay price for this
well he dies the next leader comes in
Truman nuke yeah okay boom catastrophic
what happens over there right Hiroshima
uh Reagan
Jimmy Carter
Iran didn't fear Jimmy Carter at all
they saw him as a weak man didn't seem
as a leader the day Reagan gets elected
seconds later they release prisoners of
War because they believed his threat and
Romani said hey guys let's kind of not
mess with this guy I know he's an actor
but I don't think he's acting right now
let's let's release these guys by the
way so far there's two Democrats one
Republican this is not uh George Bush
hey 911. I don't want to do the
conspiracy stuff with that part but he
comes up hey here's what we're going to
do okay uh Trump hey North Korea I dare
you see what we do okay so you have to
believe the threat when a president says
a threat whether we like it or not
whether he's your president or not
whether you voted for him or not
he made a threat to Russia publicly if
you invade Ukraine yeah here's what
we're doing so now when you make a
threat you have one of two choices and
we've all been in this position before
we're at a bar with a guy we have one
too many drinks and we tell the guy if
I'm gonna kick your ass say something
and the guy says it again like [ __ ] I
either have to kick his ass or I have to
walk away and it sucks when you're in
that position well when Biden says it to
7.7 billion people he has to follow
through with his threat so you have to
respect the fact that if he is behind
this at least your president our
president followed through on his threat
so respect to him for following through
honest threats so now let's just say it
is him let's play the game for shits and
giggles because it's entertaining and
we're having fun with it I'm gonna kick
your ass
say something Phillip say something
so let's just say he is following
through on his threat number one you
know who respects the fact that his
final throwing his threats in a dark way
Putin respects the fact that if I would
agree with that if he did yes yeah
Putin's sitting there behind closer
saying this mother is probably in his
own Russian way you know he'll say
something like that okay so now but
Putin has also made some threats okay
Putin's also said we will use nuclear if
you keep supporting Ukraine okay
when I saw this happen a couple days ago
I sat there and we were talking about
the last podcast what's the chance of a
nuclear war taking place am I like dude
it's less than five percent five to ten
percent less than five percent
this this uh you know what I mean this
this uh this kind of escalated some [ __ ]
a little bit the last 48 hours when when
when when this happened this is not a
joke to the average person they're like
oh look at that bubbles in the ocean
that's kind of cool it's it's a real
entertainment why are we why is oil
creating bubbles I'd be curious if I
swim there would it feel good the
average person who's not following all
of this stuff it's like ah it's just
bubbles in the middle of the ocean now
this is very very political very very
strategic very very intentional
and uh I think the chest the next move
is on a guy named Vladimir and uh I
think that guy knows how to play chess
and I'm really curious what his next
move is going to be yeah we had one move
this another move this week Beyond the
pipeline and that is going to the formal
process of of taking over pieces of
Ukraine which is him saying you're never
coming in again and we have a right to
do this because this is Russian
territory I
yeah that was breaking news he annexed
four regions of Ukraine yes
um so I I think that there's a couple of
pieces of this the first we already know
the answer which is the White House is
Total Line Between saying
how do I say this politely I think a lot
of American people would say I don't
want kids American kids to die in
Ukraine but I also don't want this to be
extended across Europe we do have I
think there is some residual sense that
you know we have a lot in common with
Europe based on what happened after
during and after World War II but we've
got to make it painful without making it
cost American lives and I think that
line has been towed I think pretty
effectively over the past few months if
you have had said this was the result
earlier this year in terms of paying to
Putin you'd say
that's better than I would have
I would have banked on in terms of how
much pain Putin feels I raised that
because I think to to be brutal I think
the real question isn't Ukraine the real
question is whether the pain pill is
sufficient for Putin to be saying I
can't keep doing this elsewhere in
Europe and that's where I think American
policy has made some sense make it
really really really hurt but behind
closed doors I wouldn't say this the
National Security Council without the
president but what I'm thinking is I may
be in for a dime I am not in for a
dollar I am not in for a dollar we had a
very spirited debate last podcast
Tuesday Tyler Jedediah myself Pat Vinnie
um and I said I basically took the side
that we do need to do something in
Ukraine like we can't just let uh Putin
take over uh and redraw lines in in the
middle of Europe I don't stand for it I
also agree that we shouldn't send
American lives but you know money assets
resources I stand by that they said we
don't need to be doing anything in
Ukraine stop sending money get the hell
out of it what's your position
my position is we should be telling
Russia that you can't oppress people in
a way that fundamentally violates
American values
without saying again we're in for a
dollar and for a dollar to me means
risking Americans lives by positioning
somebody told me we should have sent the
80 you know the 82nd Airborne into
um Ukraine on uh before The Invasion and
the Russians would have been deterred
and I'm like
you really need to be thinking about the
law of unintended consequences because
that's what you think that is not what
you know and if a sabotage bomb shows up
you know you're talking about sabotage
Hezbollah and Lebanon the 1980s shows up
in 150 U.S servicemen and women die what
would you then say I made a mistake
so I I think what we've done I think to
me makes sense in terms of both bringing
pain to Russia and representing American
values in the fact that we haven't done
more also makes sense to me this is not
affecting everyday Americans around the
dinner table and at the gas pump so we
should be involved but until it does
that my definition of kinetic is an
American's life is being fundamentally
changed Afghanistan yes Iraq no I would
say limited is okay this does not affect
everyday Americans life why are you
sacrificing men and women overseas to do
this what do you say about the billions
that are being spent there whereas they
could be spent elsewhere whether that's
at the border whether that's child
hunger or the money that's being spent I
I personally think too much is spent on
them if you look at our spending
military spending security spending
compared to China and Russia that we
spend too much on National Security as a
national security guy but I would say
this investment is relatively modest if
you go back to the earlier point of
deterrence we're spending a modest
amount ensuring that Putin and I'm not
sure I think this I don't know this that
Putin is saying this is not exactly
going according to plan so if I'm
thinking about Poland to the baltics
especially when you look at the lines
leaving Russia now man people aren't
that happy when you say I'm going to
conscript a bunch of people who maybe
don't want to go
spending that amount of money to ensure
that we don't have to spend trillions
for a broader European front that makes
some sense to me you say Poland and the
baltics even Finland joined uh NATO
recently is that a realistic concern
that Putin would expand his vision
Beyond Ukraine if I were in government I
would say yes because I don't anticipate
there's a difference between capability
and intent when you're in the
intelligence business what can someone
do in terms of their military capability
technical capability what do they want
to do intelligence professionals
typically overrate their ability to
understand what an adversary wants to do
what does al Qaeda want to do what does
Saddam want to do what would three years
ago what does Putin want to do I don't
think that's likely in Finland but for
me to anticipate what an adversary wants
to do you better as an analyst come in
and give me a damn good story because
otherwise I'm going to grill your ass
how do you know what somebody else
thinks how do you know what you're going
to do with your family next week at
dinner you don't know do you
you don't know you out for pizza every
Thursday you didn't go next Thursday
wise I changed my mind
don't anticipate that you can understand
perfectly what the intentions of the
adversary are unless your information is
really good
do you respect Putin
as an adversary yes as a decision maker
no
I respect the vision and I respect the
execution and the but he's put a lot of
people's lives at stake and not not just
being sort of sort of a
soft but for what is not a very
successful operation and doesn't appear
to be on the road to executing his
vision so what's up
so what's up what up dog so the okay so
that's that part let's go to the next
topic India and China okay uh and then
we'll do Iran and we'll wrap up India
China
um
there's a lot of uh animosity those two
countries have for each other okay and
it's it's a very obvious India is the
only one that publicly banned 100 apps
from China in India okay Tick Tock being
one of them
India is I think taking 25 of Apple's uh
iPhone being made over there Tim Cook
decided to move 25 over there I want to
say it's 25 or it's going to be 25 but
they're moving a lot of the
manufacturing over to India
India's uh the the star no produced the
best Engineers have been doing this for
a while with their school IIT Institute
which some people say schools MIT and
school I've been there it's an
incredible yeah it's a setup that they
have it's it's on a whole different
level people keep hiring Indian
engineers and they're fantastic on what
they're doing yes the reputation that
they've had over the years on business
is gradually changing 30 years ago 40
years ago 20 years ago 10 years ago it's
changing where trust is going higher
around the world Modi is a
pro-capitalism uh uh you know supporter
you know on what he's done obviously
he's not a perfect leader he's got his
own flaws like everybody else does but
he's he's done some great work in a
country with 44 different political
parties I don't know what the number is
but I think it's 44 give or take
political parties he's done a good job
on bringing him to where they're at
right now
what what what do you think is what do
you think of China what do you think of
India how important of a role India is
to keeping the world uh uh not relying
on 100 of China where China can impose
themselves on everybody else
and the only reason brought up India and
China is because you worked in those yes
I worked in India I did not did not work
on China but obviously I I watch it I
think we we have to deal with both I'm
and I'm a Believer in typically an
engagement not because I think it's soft
but because I think if you don't want to
use military power and you say you don't
want to talk to somebody
where do you end up like I would say you
got to engage with the Iranians you have
to do it because of the Alternatives say
we walk away from the table and we have
no capability to influence the outcome
well you're like Iran you want to
support the government that's not what I
said I said is here's got a few options
so I look at China which we can talk
about in a moment and I say I think
engagement and also understanding of
what the trajectory is in the 21st
century realistically if you look at
population growth economic growth
ability to plan decades in advance
ability to overlook when you're when
you're China and looking at African
elsewhere they don't care about human
rights we're just going to invest we
don't do that in this country in America
I think we have to figure out a way to
deal with China because if you want to
say we're going to compete with them
over Taiwan in 2035 I'm going to say
okay let's let's play that game I want
to see it gamed on paper how we're going
to do that and I want to make sure that
you know the American people are going
to support going across the Pacific to
do that so China is a different case
obviously in India I think I completely
agree on India when I used to work on
India in terms of economic regulations
in terms of global engagement in terms
of politics and diplomacy I thought
huge country huge potential as you say
educational capabilities at the upper
young 28 years old yeah incredible
um uh intellectual Talent investment
also and hard stuff like engineering and
Sciences
I think engagement economically makes
sense
politically in terms of things like
countering China I look at the attitude
of India on issues like
populism and human rights in the country
religious diversity
boy I'd be cautious I would be cautious
about getting too close in terms of
seeing them as a natural partner because
I think Moses who I think Modi does not
see the world in the way we do in terms
of what he sees for the future that's a
Hindu country it's not a multi-ethnic
country for him I think and that's going
to cause if you look at the History of
Violence ethnic and religious violence
in India I would not have High Hopes
about stability in that country over the
long term really I'm not talking about
Revolution I'm just talking about stuff
the government does where Americans in
Congress and elsewhere cringe and say
wow we don't want to be in bed with
those people I am I man
that country has a history of who who do
you fear more demo or China long term
China okay I wouldn't say fear I would
say uh if we think we can conformidable
enemies yes that's exactly right that's
how yeah that's right just just again
population growth economic growth
ability to plan investment in the
military and
uh geography if you look at access to
the Pacific obviously into Taiwan we
keep thinking you know we will defend
Taiwan good luck
good luck
and tell the Americans that we're going
to do that over the course of time with
the military and economics and a
population of that size good luck the
American politicians say it I want to
see it gamed out
yeah I don't think there's any uh
American fervor to go to war over Taiwan
and and and Biden once again I think
speaks said it though yeah but he's
again it's like when he when he got out
in front of Obama saying Obama supports
same-sex marriage a guy speaks before he
thinks
he said that and I'd say have you have
you wargamed out that in in The
Situation Room good luck especially as
the years pass and China keeps growing
and keeps investing
good luck 81 million people voted for
this guy to to lead the Free World and
so we we have to you know trust in the
fact that 81 million people chose him to
be the right guy to lead these types of
situations you know Biden but
unfortunately every single time he says
something people who voted for him keep
saying yeah but that's not what he meant
and uh he shouldn't have said that I
mean how many times you shouldn't have
to say that every day you should have
better things to do in your life than
say he shouldn't have said that you know
what I mean it's a little bit of a
challenge when you have to keep
defending the person that you support it
but okay let's talk Iran let's go to
Iran uh Iran we're seeing obviously
what's happened in Iran this is day 13.
yesterday was day 12 today's day 13. uh
it's it's constant ongoing uh the 22
year old lady when this whole anti-job
movement started
it's become a phenomenon just to give
them some statistics on what's happened
day 13 of the Revolution Martyrs 240
people killed injured thousands detained
12 000. protests continue in 162 cities
uh yesterday I was on uh Iran
International uh news uh Channel they
were interviewing me talking about what
I think is going on in Iran but for you
you worked in Iran 85 this is khomeini's
ERA this is post shop six years post
Shaw uh CIA gets a lot of criticism and
credit to helping the Shah uh become the
emperor because they hurt mosa there
you'll hear that hear that story quite
often yeah but then you'll also hear
that the CIA was also involved in
helping the shaw fall and how many show
up so both ways you know you'll hear
some stories that have come up on the
fact that support wasn't given when it
was promised and when Carter goes in
there and said we're going to help you
you Kissinger says we got your back they
never got us back Revolution got bigger
it's too late the rest is history so
from from your experience from what you
know whether it's mosadev to Shah the
revolution is 79 to today are the
chances of a revolution happening again
and if yes what's needed just give me
your story of Iran your experience
fairly broad question
um
how do I break this down I saw the
security I followed the security
apparatus not in Iran but outside Iran
as an intelligence Analyst at the agency
I thought the security apparatus was
brutal aggressive and by that I mean as
a security official professional seeing
what they were willing to do in terms of
supporting for example for overseas
militant movements in places like
Lebanon far more aggressive in some ways
than we might be
um
I thought the west and this is something
I I talk about a lot of people don't
like this but I thought the West had
limited ability to analyze in Iran
because there's something called the
halo effect and intelligence analysis
that is you're looking at the Iranian
opposition and making them putting Halos
on them they think like we do they want
a more liberal sort of uh democracy
there's a theocracy now as you know in
Iran that prevents most candidates from
running it is not a democratic system I
think Americans tend to too quickly say
this is going to succeed because those
people are doing the right thing
everybody must think like that who
doesn't want to have not have to wear a
job who doesn't want to live in a
Democratic Society and of course there
are a lot of people who think like that
so I think the willingness of the
Iranian security apparatus to suppress
the people couple with maybe an
overestimation in America about how many
people might support the regime means
that I I would say prospects of
Revolution are modest at best what
percentage would you put on the
less than five percent no uh ten percent
not really that high
one in ten I'm talking about over the
course of let's say 10 or 20 years got
it so you're not even the chance of it
happening right now it's not high
numbers no what I I would look for it
this to analyzing one of the hardest
things I saw in in at the agency is
trying to analyze public movements I
think it's easier with social media
but I would be breaking this down into
uh specific areas like geography how
many places are seeing unrest geography
over time is that going on for months to
be blunt willingness of the people to
take a bullet one thing I'd like to say
typically in these kinds of
movements you need some kind of
leadership to coalesce around I don't
see a great amount of leadership in in
the Iranian opposition and then on the
converse side tough questions like how
willing is the security apparatus to
kill people over time is there
dissonance within the the military and
political leadership about this
there's a lot if I were doing hardcore
analysis which we're not doing I'm not
I'm not denigrating this I'm just saying
this is this would take weeks to step
through all those elements of successful
Revolution successful counter Revolution
to understand whether that 10 figure is
solid but my sense going back to it is
there are a lot of people who still
support the regime and the security
apparatus don't underestimate them not
only are they good they will kill they
and they will kill thousands if that's
what it takes as far as regime change in
the next 10 years low
Iran
North Korea Russia would you put those
in order of it in terms of regime change
like uh
toppled Revolution yeah not necessarily
you're not saying like a new person is
going to replace Putin because that's
probably going to happen next time yeah
he's you're saying a regime yes oh okay
all right go ahead
I'd put around third
um
Russia and North Korea the problem I'm
facing with North Korea is that's one
bullet which I don't really I mean
Russia is the same way
maybe Russia won North Korea to Iran
three I'd have to in terms of likelihood
of a regime change so you're putting a
run at the bottom of the list meaning
that's the least likely to happen over
the next time but but among three that
are volatile now you give me two beers
and I might reorder those something
tells me if we had a couple beers to
fill up much I actually think it would
be a fun conversation no you know I I
think listen to me people think like oh
my God like I love bringing people that
we may have this disagreements with and
we can have the conversations but I also
love reading tip O'Neill's book not to
point Chris Matthews book on uh Tip
O'Neill and uh Reagan you know like
these guys would go at it and afterwards
they're having a beer or Irish talking
laugh and joke in sports all this stuff
I think that's how it needs to be I have
a discourse you know have your debate
have your conversations and then
afterwards sit down and say dude we have
differences but let's talk how's life
how you doing how's everything it's
interesting to take you inside CNN for
just a moment one there's only been and
I'm not going to name names maybe two
people that I've been in the green room
with I didn't care for and I used to do
I'd say do CNN regularly now before
covid I was on it every day the
definition of the people who I didn't
like in the green room is they brought
the conversation and typically to
dispute to The Green Room I'm like
that's an amateur move we can debate on
camera and the debates were real there's
different and then they in the Green
Room what are you doing this weekend
what's going on
um funny story not that I disagree with
me that's a very nice guy John Dean to
talk about how how pleasant and
interesting The Green Room is I was
telling John Dean who's a senator from
no no I'm talking about John Dean from
from Watergate oh gosh uh who's to be
blown up I'm thinking of Howard John
Dean we're in there one day he's a super
nice guy and a good sense of humor I'm a
runner I'm like man my knees are
starting to hurt me he pulls up his pant
leg and he says you need these kind of
knee bands these I'm talking John Dean
from Watergate is in the green room
talking about his grandkids and telling
me what kind of knee bands to wear
because he's got them on and then he
rolls up that's the Green Room not what
did you say on camera screw you you
nobody does that an agreement except an
amateur and I'm saying as you're
suggesting Tip O'Neill and Reagan we
should have more of that in Washington I
agree well we're at the end of the
podcast this is fun guys we have to go
because he and I have to fight outside
but uh for for everybody else that you
know you watch it if you enjoyed this
there's a couple things I want to tell
you number one I am convinced the future
looks bright I'm so convinced I can't
even tell you by the way these hats that
we customize like literally I've been
working on these things for six months
now to make it exactly the way I like
you with the help of Kai and our team
it's finally here okay it's a value
table logo on the front on the side of
it it says future looks bright and on
the bottom here it says future looks
bright with the valetime logo on the
inside we have them in black red and
white yes uh two days ago we announced
this on a couple of videos they're about
to sell out most people are ordering all
three colors for themselves there's
different sizes large small that you can
have but uh
I'm about the mindset of having the
concept of the future looks bright
around you affirmations around you
there's a lot of mess going on right now
in the world there's a lot of negative
things going on around the world right
now but if you haven't yet ordered yours
do so before they sell out we will
obviously put another order in but it'll
take us another 12 weeks to come in but
for those of you guys that want these
future looks bright hats now click on
the link below to go to vtmerch.com to
get your hats and I suggest ordering all
three and if you got friends that are
valuetainers ordered for them as well uh
final you you have a book you wrote a
the we were looking at the book that you
wrote if you don't mind sharing that
with the audience I've written a few
books the last one which was a book
called black side about CI facilities if
you want to talk about it you can find
me on LinkedIn at Philip Mudd my photos
there I don't have any information up
because you're looking at the entire
Philip Mudd corporate Enterprise
including sadly the ethics office very
active on Tick Tock and Instagram and I
see you like hardcore active you're
doing music videos yeah
did you know Coolio just died
unbelievable
Michelle Pfeiffer the movie you know the
I'll sing that if you have higher
learning really I'm impressed by the way
you know that guy made an impact that
was on the cover of the Wall Street
Journal Coolio really straight up best
comment of the day can I give you guys
the best comment of the day
here's the best comment of the day did
you see it or no I don't know it said
it said
you know uh Phil looks like he could be
related to Adam it could be his father
or his Uncle you guys look very like you
could be family that's why I think he's
a very good looking guy both of you guys
are good-looking men here anyways we
enjoyed it guys take care have a great
weekend be safe we'll do it again next
week take everybody bye-bye bye bye-bye
thanks for having me